elle est la femme d'El chapo Guzman
voici l'histoire d'Emma Coronel la
complice du plus puissant parrain du
cartel de Sinaloa
et ma coronelle c'est pas une bimbo
idiote elle vient du serrage
[Musique]
nous sommes en juillet 2015 dans la
prison la plus sécurisée du Mexique le
narcotrafiquant el chapo Guzman s'évade
par un tunnel d'un kilomètre et demi
creusé jusqu'à la douche de sa cellule
c'est le roi des tunnels el chapozman
pour tracer ce tunnel le les ingénieurs
qui l’engagent ont besoin d'un GPS pour
situer la cellule d'El chapo et
macaronelle a remis à El chapo une
montre dans laquelle il y a un GPS pour
pouvoir tracer ce tunnel et donc quelque
part elle est complice de l'évasion de
son épouse
sociale de l'altiplôme à la mort de
Pablo Escobar en 1993 les cartels
mexicains qui assuraient jusqu'à présent
le rôle de transporteur prenne la main
sur le trafic de drogue dans les
montagnes du sinanoa au nord-ouest du
pays un homme montre rapidement les
échelons du crime organisé
Joachim Guzman dit el chapo et le
chapeau ça veut dire le petit Pinet dans
un hameau autour d'une petite
municipalité qui s'appelle Badiraguato
qui est dans l'état de synallora c'est
vraiment le berceau du narcotrafic c'est
un enfant pauvre il est quasiment
illettré il se lance dans la production
de marijuana et puis il devient tueur il
montre comme ça les échelons et c'est au
début des années 2000 qui va avoir son
explosion avec un associé qui s'appelle
Ismaël el Mayo zambada les cartels
mexicains assoie le hégémonie ils
détiennent à présent le monopole du
trafic de drogue vers les États-Unis le
premier marché mondial le cartel de
Sinaloa est le plus puissant d'entre eux
elle chapeau n'est pas le chef du cartel
de Sina LOA c'est un des chefs d'une
fédération de parrain qui a joué un rôle
très important et surtout un rôle
médiatique il a été très admiré avec des
belles femmes des avions des belles
voitures etc et donc il a représenté une
forme de modèle de narco culture en
Mexique en 2006 le président mexicain
fraîchement élu Felipe Calderon déclare
la guerre au narcotrafiquants des
milliers de militaires sont déployés à
travers tout le pays
ça explosé les cartels se sont armés
encore davantage et aujourd'hui on parle
de 350 000 morts quasiment tout le
territoire mexicain est concerné par des
violences criminelles dans sa guerre
contre les cartels Felipe et Calderon
s'appuient sur un homme fort son
ministre de la Sécurité publique Gennaro
Garcia Luna
c'était le tsar anti drogue c'est lui
qui prend la tête de de cette guerre
contre les cartels
il y avait très peu de de dirigeants du
cartel de Sinaloa qui était arrêté ce
qui était arrêté était des dissidents en
fait on s'aperçoit qu'il travaillait
pour un cartel qui est le cartel de
signaloir c'est à dire qu'il a favorisé
ce cartel vis-à-vis d'autres en arrêtant
ses adversaires et en laissant passer
des cargaisons de drogue aux États-Unis
en février 2023 jennaro Garcia Luna est
reconnu coupable par la justice
américaine de corruption et de trafic de
cocaïne
nextrine
alors c'est en 2006 que que el chapo
Guzman rencontre Emma coronelle au cours
d'un bal il danse avec Emma coronale il
tombe amoureux d'elle et il se trouve
que elle se présente un concours de
reine de beauté et le jour où elle
présente sa candidature et l'organisme
une fête el chapeaux Guzman débarque
avec des centaines d'hommes armés dans
ce petit bout et il la demande en
mariage
[Musique]
comme au ciel
très très rapidement ils auront ils
auront des enfants
nous sommes en janvier 2016 dans l'état
du synalloa en cavale depuis son évasion
spectaculaire de la prison la plus
sécurisée du Mexique el chapo Guzman est
finalement arrêté
dans la résidence qui lui sert de
planque la police mexicaine découvre un
véritable arsenal qui comprend notamment
deux voitures blindées et un
lance-grenade el chapo Guzman est
interpellé alors qu'il essayait une
nouvelle fois de s'échapper par un
tunnel
est finalement extradé vers les
États-Unis pour y être jugé
lors de son procès à New York en 2018 sa
compagne Emma Coronel vient plaider sa
cause on la voit avec des lunettes de
Gucci elle est présente à toutes les
audiences donc elle est très médiatisée
était un arcotrafiquant il a été arrêté
en 2013 et son oncle surtout Nacho
Coronel ignation colonel est un des
associés dès le chapeau Guzman
donc elle chapeau Ousmane il choisit une
épouse qui quelque part va respecter
l'omerta ma chieuse et qui connaît déjà
son milieu
des époux possible parallèlement à ça on
la découvre sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Instagram ce compte suivi par plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'abonnés et dont
elle nie être à l'origine documente sa
vie privée
on la découvre en bikini on la découvre
avec un maillot des Yanis son équipe de
baseball préférée on la voit tirer à la
carabine et donc elle elle joue un peu
un rôle justement de bimbo
d'influenceuse
c'est pas une bimbo idiote elle a fait
des études de journalisme elle est allée
à l'université elle sait communiquer et
ma coronelle se livre au jeu des
interviews télévisées et apparaît même
dans cartel crew l'émission de
téléréalité américaine qui met en scène
des femmes de narcos
en 2019 el chapo Guzman est finalement
condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
deux ans plus tard c'est au tour d'Emma
coronelles d'être rattrapé par la
justice américaine elle reconnaît avoir
une connaissance de l'importation de
grande quantités de drogues vers les
États-Unis et admet sa participation à
l'évasion de son mari en 2015
de trois ans de prison une peine
clémente qui selon certains observateurs
s'expliquent par sa possible
collaboration avec la justice américaine
cette thèse n'est qu'une thèse son
avocate en tout cas ni cette information
et ma coronelle purge actuellement sa
peine dans une prison pour femme au
Texas elle devrait être libérée à la fin
de l'année 2023 les témoins protégés ils
changent d'identité ils vivent caché sur
le sol américain bien et protégé si elle
ne revient pas au Mexique par exemple ça
sera quand même un indice la loi du
silence est très forte et si on parle on
meurt
[Musique]